okay uh this is the latest from the
scene of uh an
accident involving the golfer tiger
woods and you can see for yourself that
was the vehicle he was traveling in
he was cut from it by the los angeles
county sheriff's department and
presumably other emergency
services it's been described as a roll
over accidents involving no
other vehicles the vehicle the la county
sheriff's department said
sustained major damage let's cut
straight to though the condition of
tiger woods he was cut
from the vehicle extricated as the la
county sheriff's department
says and has been transported to a local
hospital
by ambulance for his injuries
unspecified at the moment what his
injuries are
um he was let me tell you
we'll get it get a map on it as well but
somebody might uh
i know these locations he was in the
rolling hills estates
and uh between there and rancho palos
verdes uh the vehicle was traveling
northbound on
hawthorne boulevard at black horse road
when it crashed
the vehicle as we say sustained major
damage and uh
such was the uh condition of the the
vehicle
after that accident that the la county
sheriff's department says that mr woods
as i say was extricated from the wreck
with what's called the jaws of life
you'll be familiar
with them in this country they are some
of the uh the cutting equipment that
emergency services
carry to to prise apart to cut relevant
bits
of the vehicle apart to get to the
occupant
but we still have been given no detail
uh about the condition of tiger woods
apart from the fact that he's been taken
to a local hospital
by ambulance for his injuries uh
a story we are monitoring very closely
for you and we'll bring you the
very latest on that as we hear it tiger
woods set in a single vehicle
rollover accident cut from the vehicle
and is
now being treated in hospital